[Musique]
voilà il s'agit de faire un saut de
mouton par deux c'est un bouton en
dessin alors je vais cadre et le fonds
des corps sur une caméra c'est la 4
qu'il n'est pas toujours pas branché et
qui ne laissera bientôt cameramen
virevolter leurs cadres - ca et le cube
fera la place du mouton
ce cube bleu dans l'espace vous aurez
donc à sauter par dessus ce cube et vous
sauterez par la même occasion par dessus
ses moutons sur le dessin face à l'udc
oui vous parisien avait toute la famille
va sauter et toulouse cité sur une
partie de ce bouton voit le dessin
aggraverait 6e tout va bien max c'est
complet à la une près de lacolle voilà
c'est très bien ça va ça bouge encore un
peu vis non de trop voilà vous démolit v
max blancardi
ouais structure centre le moteur donne
du match plein cadre encore voilà très
bien
enfin bouger la 2 maintenant la deux
c'était cadré regarde moi pas de retard
[Musique]
mademoiselle très gentil des serviettes
pour rendre le passage des faire le
mouton gentiment tu donnes la
surimpression match
[Musique]
bien vous voulez en jambes et cette
petite construction là allez y sauter
par dessus
allez hop bon passer de compter comme ça
plusieurs fois oui aujourd'hui le bouton
consiste à les scanner voilà voilà à la
continuer hop bien alors tout à fait mis
en place allons-y frêle chanter le
mouton est facile de faire des choses
comme ça c'est pas du tout mon possible
sur sa tombe et non 1 s'il vous plaît
procédons d'image
voilà une fois
[Musique]
et bien des fois votre famille lesquels
un mois je vois bien
bon je crois que nous en france nous
apporte
[Musique]
voilà alors je vais sur situé devant
nous allons c'est avec de braine et tous
les techniciens qui sont ici la tête de
ce monsieur on va la mettre sur le corps
de la petite fille alors c'est très
simple on couvre le corps de ce monsieur
avec une un voile bleu de manière à
incruster son corps dans le fond du
décor voilà vous ne bougez plus vous
avez bien cette caméra et quand la
petite fille
on va lui mettre la cagoule sur la tête
attention hein ça c'est pas mal mais
voilà voilà
alors de brel à toi élargi la petite
élargie de petite fille ou
réciproquement
on dégage cette attention attendait
tucci et goûtons monsieur up attention
hop voilà fraîche fois que vous y retire
georges tous les deux de manière à ce
qu'on puisse faire le trucage tranquille
ferait grossir un peu la tête de la
petite fille là encore encore encore et
la remontée est large et un peu voilent
armes et des bras monsieur et voilà
mon cher agresseurs c'est l'heure de la
confusion c'est d'abord il faut que je
dise je sais où je suis ton oui
infinivault joly c'est très libéraux non
l'attendait haletant guillaume g du
combiné qui reste des fois deux heures
comme ça puis c'est très commode quand
on change de directeur chez ya que
furent la honte
alors j'avoue j'abrège nos commentaires
verser jacques l'histoire est toujours
je vous remercie d'être venus je reviens
sur agnès el-arish je remercie tous les
productions de la télévision et je
remercie ceux sans qui le progiciel de
télévision n'aurais pas de raison
d'exister public les téléspectateurs
[Musique]